[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borsch and this is how to become a grand
master
now this is not the first step of a
series you see here on this english
chess club you start out as how to
become an nm with a caleb danby then you
learn about chess and psychology with
dorsa as she teaches you how to meddle
with your opponent's mind and just try
to figure out what they're thinking and
just mess it all up now this one is how
to become a grand master
and here i talk about
the early phases
of grand masters
so talking about ways they become a
grand master and games that were
extremely important
in fact this is the continuation
of the series about richard rapport
i know if you guys are familiar with
richard rapport but if not
well you're
about to know a little bit more about
him
he was born in hungary in shea he became
a grand master at age 13 which is still
a good result even if you become a grand
master today at age 13 you are
considered to be a prodigy
however
there are some differences in becoming a
grand master then and now because of it
more and more technology that we can use
the easier it gets but of course there
are
benefits negatives and positives but
we're not gonna get into that detail
now rapport is famous for very exciting
sharp chests
so this very first one this very first
puzzle i want to show
is him playing against hushenbeth who's
also a grand master from germany
now
in this position
white don't seem to be having like an
immediate advantage in fact he is down
material
quite badly a couple of pawns
but there is something that makes this
position
somewhat better for white
before trying to solve it i would love
to ask
what do you think is the difference that
could make this position a little bit
more favorable for white
than for black
also hello everyone here
and the st louis chess club and also on
youtube and twitch
um what's the plan for today kantel from
the title
exactly that
so
yeah
okay so many suggestions and thank you
for all the suggestions for future
streams
be happy to look through and obviously
we're gonna look at people becoming
grand masters
won't look at all of the super gms but
some specific ones and by the way if you
have someone you'd suggest that you'd
love to know more about definitely let
us know either in the chat or in the
comments later on
so when you look at this position
i always start with the kings
because it's the game of kings it's a
royal game that's all we care for
now
the difference between these two kings
is the king on e1 is actually much safer
can anybody tell me what is the reason
this king feels safe safer than the
counterpart on e8
there is simple reason for that
uh can you repeat sorry
black has no checks yes
and what does white have that black does
not
and by the way chat don't be discouraged
you can also
give your comment
the death valley of chess for sure this
is what is called the death valley of
chess
if you open it up it's very easy to get
checkmated
so that's a great observation right
there
that king can't get into a lot of
trouble but apart from that there is a
mighty mighty eagle on e6
just
cramping down black's position this
bishop
is sort of smothered by its own pawns
and can't really move
and that is the reason why white's
position is just better and superior to
blacks
because black is just not able to move
around
however
the fact that you're sort of paralyzing
your opponent's pieces is not enough to
win a game it's a good start because
they can't improve
however you'll have to find a way to
crash on through
right now
this moment
hushenbeth is attacking that rook on a7
but
just because they're attacking a piece
of arts that doesn't mean we have to
defend it what can we do
that could counter
someone attacking our pieces
what would be equally as powerful
counter attacking
so here white goes knight c5
a lot of times
we kind of
realize at the default setting oh i've
got my rook attacked i'm just going to
move it away however if you move your
rook away you're sort of losing the
threat of the game your pieces are not
roaming in and your attack just
loses
its
real strength so
he goes knight c5
the point of knight c5 is
if you take here and it happened in the
game i have a double attack on d7
mind you it's not just a double attack
it's also attacking a pinned piece
if that knight ever moves
that rook on c8 is going to be in danger
so for that reason hushenbeth decides to
take on a7
naturally we capture back
to check
king d8
was there a possibility to go with queen
c2 as well well it's a nice little trick
um basically
building on the idea
of the death valley of chess as it is
called
because it captures
haha we check you you can't move away
you can't move to these squares
g6
and because we like queen sacrifices we
would take this way take and its
checkmate
which is kind of elegant however black
is not at all forced to play this way
you're not
going to
take on a7 you're gonna realize oh you
want to check me there and either you
block or you bring a piece there to
block that check
so for that very reason knight c5 is a
little bit more aggressive because it
directly attacks that knight on d7
queen takes a7
bishop takes
king d8
and this is the moment we're going to
stop for a second
you look at this position and you have
to sort of come up with
possible continuations for white
what sort of moves would pop into your
head
while you look at this one
there's some moves that are
simple
simple easy moves
but you can go from simple to
complicated
we can go and do the wild knight e6
check yep that is an idea
what else can we do apart from knight e6
check
so we're sort of looking through all the
possible motions and moves that we could
do in the position
and by the way if you just decide oh i'm
just going to go move my rook to the
open file
never really fret there's always a 50 50
chance you're going to succeed it's
either good
or bad
those are the two options however if
you're looking for
more moves and
different moves and that
if you compare them you have a highly
and a much likelier chance of succeeding
so we have knight e6 as one move what
else would come to our mind here
as white
you've got queen g4 yeah
these moves are all very very daring and
ambitious
however
they're simple moves
chess isn't always about sparkling
combinations sometimes it is about them
but
there are moments
where you just want to take whatever you
can take right
so obviously we can capture on c8 like
da
free stuff
just give it to give it to me
give me all the free stuff
or you could also take on b5
i actually love the audience that we
have here because none of you seem
excited about taking material it's only
me
and it's great
because
if i'd ask this
in
a real tournament everyone's i'm gonna
take pawns pieces queens whatever just
give it to me just give it to me i'll be
happy
you've seen this idea of queen g4
but
in comes richard richard
plays this game that not many do
he plays this game
for checkmate
i know
i know it's
a little bit of an old-fashioned way of
looking at this game but it's true if
you made your opponent's king
you win
so is there a way
we could set up maiden
one in this position
yeah queen h5
was dolly played
by
rapport setting up the idea of queen ea
checkmate
and here
rockport's grandmaster opponent did not
disappoint
he didn't miss checkmate played pawn to
g6
otherwise obviously queen 8 is mate
so g6
however
what makes rapport so good
is that not only he plays
with
a lot of energy
he also have a wild wild imagination
i almost said wild wild west
but i really shouldn't say it right now
any case
there are some meeting patterns in this
position
that uh
rapport is going to use to full effect
so oftentimes we are sort of getting
panicky our queens attacked oh my god oh
my god the queen's under attack what are
we going to do
but
in chess
it doesn't always matter that much
we can just go
and take this pawn
because if captures then there's knight
e6 made
there's nothing you can do there
so that is one of those ideas bishop
takes b5 if you capture
there's knight e6
mate
however
chess becomes a little bit more
complicated
once your opponent knows what you're
trying to do
how could black try
to create a pathway for this king to
escape
pawn to c6
with the point that the king is trying
to elope
via c7 in fact this is what happened in
the game
with c6 however
rapport expected this move
and play an utter brilliancy
exactly so queen d5 check
pawn takes
e6 checkmate
quite a cute solution but it shows
rapport saw the mating patterns early on
but
didn't lose faith once he saw c6 found
this idea of queen d5 check
here black decided to resign because
after king c7 you are just going to get
checkmated
by white's pieces
and otherwise there's just no hope at
all if you go here i check you here and
with made to follow i'm just going to
checkmate you check here i'm mate
but it kind of shows
that
once you learn the pattern you can base
your play around it
so patterns are important but they're
just part of the solution
you really have to make sure
that that pattern is going to justify
your play and that's what rapport did
here
justified the play now we're going to do
something that we did before
in the previous lectures i'm going to
show how he built this position because
this is sort of the end game how he
finished it off and wanted in style
but it had a buildup
so let's go to this game
d4 so
but this has to
start with a little bit of a backstory
so rockport
um of course was a big prodigy
and not only did he know
these very topical lines early on
he could mix them too so he would play
d4 he'd play knight f3 he plays c4
in this game he went for d4
but i wanted to mention a little bit of
a story that i had with him
now in chess there's not much hackling
going on
in fact people
are supposed to stay quiet
when they play the game of chess
so
i happened to play him
but it wasn't just like your everyday
tournament that you play it was a team
championship
but in team championships you can sort
of switch around the lineups
i was playing on first board
and i was substituting
one of his friends
at that moment
and i didn't know it was either i'm
playing his coach
his coach then
i mean rockport's coach
or i'm going to play rockport
and um
i don't know whom to expect they were a
little bit late
for the tournament game
and then i saw knight on f3
on move one on the board and then i saw
richie sitting at the board
and um
so
i was like okay
this is surprising i'm playing richard
rapport
and was pondering
and then i hear
from the next board
move
there's like
move
what
move
and i realized
the coach
who was heckling me that i'm not moving
it's just move one make a move
and it was kind of funny because you
never really have any sort of
interaction at all ever
so it was sort of exciting to see
exciting it was shocking to me that he
was
sort of urging me to move
ironically enough
rapport actually started to have a
similar tendency himself he doesn't make
moves immediately when he's starting his
game he gets into the zone
sort of similar thing that i had myself
and by the way karma did strike i did
win that game so
even though that was the only time i got
hackled while playing a chess game i did
win it so
karma is sometimes good
that that was a good karma
any case let's go back to the game
itself
d4
this is the game and this actually has
been very very popular recently
not much
because of the
kramnik kasparov matches but because of
karana karana actually kind of started
playing this again and
had decent results against carlson
but
actually this game
is years years before that
everyone here plays pawn to e3
or queen a4 check
but very few plays knight c3 and knight
c3 is this typical move by rapport
rapport is ready for a fight
rapport is trying
to control some very important squares
however this comes at a price
he lost the pawn
you're gonna get some control
so ocean beth plays a6
e4
b5
e5
knight d5
so you see that position
blank has that extra pawn
but there's some other costs
that uh actually black
will have to pay for like he's paying
for the fact
that um
he defended that pawn
what is the price black is paying
for that
uh yes partly the center control but
apart from the central control what's
the difference
development very good very very good
so in fact
in the opening phase you want to get a
good control in the center
but the second but not least important
step is to castle somehow as quickly as
possible you want to castle
but here black was actually wasting
quote unquote wasting time because it's
good to be up a pawn however it comes at
the price of not developing your king
side where you usually castle
so richie actually goes for a4
and puts pressure
on black's pieces
bishop b7
and probably the move the key move of
the game
that
gives him the initiative
e6
this is the move that i call sabotage
that bishop is gonna fry there on f8
it's not gonna get out
and it'll take extra moves to get out
from
f8 if i let's say go bishop e2 which of
course is a nonsensical move i could go
e6 and then two moves i could castle
compare that to this case let's say
again i go bishop e2 as rockport did
it'll take one two three four moves to
castle
so two extra moves to make it to safety
knight takes b takes queen d5
and
all of these moves seem natural
however
black already committed
one of the sins in chess
neglected development
however
there is sin number two
what is that second sin
that black committed
and it's quite important
well doubled upon but he was sort of
forced
to live with that
it's not the end of the world it's not
great don't get me wrong it's not great
but it's not the end of the world
yep
it's something called the early morning
rule
you don't want to wake up her majesty
too early
why well
she is going to run into trouble
so most of the time you don't want to
get her out there because she's just
going to become a target
and richie notices this
plays knight g5 then the intention of
going bishop f3 so black again will have
to move the queen
because if you go g6 i go bishop f3 and
i win your bishop
there's no way you can defend it you
move there and i capture
so even though knight g5 sacrifices
another pawn but it sort of forces black
to waste additional time
so queen takes g2
rook f1
knight d7
knight takes e6
and now you can see like the whole
combination forming
already sort of
rapport is forcing hushenbeth into a bad
position
rook c8
a b a b
a b a b and now he gets the open file
rook a7
queen c6
bishop g4 and the rest we know because
we just looked at it a minute ago
queen b6 knight c5 etc etc
so if we kind of think about it
what were the reasons
rapport succeeded in this game
any thoughts there chad and everyone
here
any thoughts you're no bad thoughts by
the way anytime you're thinking about
reasons
why you succeed or sometimes fail
you're becoming a better player
well of course initiative was an
important part
but
ah there's a good point there in chat
saying greed greed was a bad guide
for hushenbath for sure the fact that
he went for
picking cherries
on rockport's kingside could have been
partly the reason
for his downfall
but the other reason i think was
neglecting
king's safety
he could almost get a wave at the fact
that he moved his queen around
it's not ideal you shouldn't do it
but
it's something you could do
sometimes it's not the best but you can
do it it does happen
they're like specific lines where it
actually
does work
however
the biggest reason why houston beth lost
is because his king was stuck in the
middle
all right
so now i'm going to show you a game
by rapport
that
was sort of interesting
for the sense that you might be
wondering okay
e4 d5 let's even look from rockport's
perspective
knight c3 e takes d5
this is very much dreaded
by people
um i'm pretty sure you guys know the
name
of this variation
it's called
the exchange french
it's dreaded because it is so tiring
not so exciting it's
it's kind of stale
um
not as
boring as the london
but still boring
so he takes z5
e takes d5
bishop d3 knight f6
so
i'm going to show it to you and i want
to show you
that even though the position might not
seem that exciting
ropport is still
willing
to put pressure on his opponent
slowly but surely knight e2
castles castles okay
so we get a symmetrical position
and a symmetrical position
usually
is indicating that the game is going to
end in a draw one way or another
what should we do
in a case if a position
is too symmetrical what should we do and
obviously
we're playing
like ritchie rockport we're trying to
win of course
well double opening developing in by in
itself isn't going to help us
we got to create some imbalance that is
correct store-bought we got to create
some imbalances how can we create some
imbalances
so if you actually trade a bishop for a
night
we're going to create an imbalance
our opponent is going to have more
bishops
but it's already not the same
now
rapport actually does the same thing he
doesn't take here
because he believes this bishop is very
good at defending and it's true if you
take take
a lot of times the dark squares will be
sort of
weak
and that bishop will be missed
so he does exactly what you're saying
c6 but takes off the other bishop
so let's say if
white would go here he'd go bishop g4
and think about exchanging of that
bishop
just creating an imbalance
c6 knight g3
bishop g4 and this is just pure
provocation
by richard um he's saying okay
we're not trading anything
but i'm putting pressure on your queen
are you going to move your queen
you're going to move your queen there
you're just putting yourself into a pin
you're going to move the bishop here
well i might change my mind
bring my bishop back and say well your
bishop used to be good on d3 but now
it's bad on e2
so he's sort of trying to probe
neubauer's position just a little bit
so
knight ce2
blocks it
rookie 8
just developing simple stuff knight d7
c3 bishop f8
so
richie is not in a rush
he's slowly amping up some pressure but
also is making sure his king is safe and
that he got all of his pieces developed
queen c2
g6
and one of the problems you often
get into
is that you get impatient in these
positions but if you're patient enough
eventually things are going to get
better for you
and patience is paying off right now why
plays f3
can anybody tell me
why f3 is somewhat of a subpar move it's
not losing
it's not outright bad
but it's not
the move that white would be looking
forward to
what could be wrong with pawn to f3
and we're sort of
focusing on long term here
weakens the e3 square yes
what else
so not only
are there some holes
on the e file
but we also have future
pressure on the diagonal and that's why
i'm always saying to people
keep these guardian pawns where they're
at maybe push the h one even here h3
feels like the more natural response
because it creates a little lift it's
okay for your king
and your king is safe
whenever you push these pawns even
though sometimes if you have like an
aggressive plan you can start rolling
the pawn down
but clearly that's not the plan
for white here
there's just clearly weakening
the dark squares
which which he is going to use
bishop e6
rookie 1 queen b6 b4 a5
finding some play
a3 bishop e7 bishop c1
and now knight e5
and from all these little inaccuracies
rapport is building up a very very nice
position for himself probably he's
already better
because you can't avoid this trade for
the
bishop for the knight
and then already black has the bishop
pair to work with
it's not the end of the world
for white
but it's already something
to brag about for rapport
f4
take sticks
queen a6
so
the thing is
that
white is going for some aggressive play
and it's either going to work out for
white or not that can also become a
weakness someone in the chat is
mentioning the totem pole of pieces that
is correct
it's quite a sight you don't really see
this too often
but
if your pieces are over defended it's
not such a bad thing to have also the
fact that you've got this pin
makes this thing and this whole
construction work
so f4 takes takes queen a6 of course
richie is not interested
in a very aggressive tussle on the king
side
because he knows in the long term
the bishop pair is going to favor him
queen takes and probably queen takes a6
is not a great move uh martin should
have played some like queen f3 and tried
to go for the aggressive attack
that would have been a better play
however
it's very difficult
for
the opponent to switch
the meta gaming now that's one of those
things you learn
from chess in psychology another class
the same this chess club that oftentimes
switching gears is difficult so if your
opponent is really scared of you
and they have to attack you that's
actually advantageous for you because
they weren't ready yet they were already
kind of deciding okay whatever happens
a peaceful result is all i need they're
not ready to win the game
how i don't know it does sound a little
bit funny but it's true some people
sort of resign themselves okay my only
goal this game is to make a draw
so here no power plays f4 but then
decides to take on a6 and i believe
that's the reason for this move
that he's trying to stay solid
instead of playing to the demands of the
position and that is really chess and
psychology
so takes
f5 he's still aggressive
but i mean f5 isn't as good
here when
you could have a queen on the board and
it almost would prove to be lethal now
of course it's not the end of the world
it still would be a fighting game but
i'd rather have the queen on the board
instead
richie of course trades because he
doesn't want to get mated weirdly enough
takes takes
rookie one
involving the rook
in the game
rook f1
knight e1
the question we have to answer
is that f pawn
edible
and it's not a simple yes and no
question
believe it or not
it's more complicated than that
to take or not to take
the answer is not tactical in nature i
beg to differ it is tactical in
involving nature c3
uh knight takes what
c3 um
what are you thinking um
takes then you take here
okay
good point
knight takes c3
and if i take here
that's correct and now not only are
you're defending it with a check
but you're also capturing that very good
so knight c3 is one option
and there's another one which i call the
venus fly trap
of chess
ship f6 and if i take here
yeah that rook really wants to escape
doesn't want to make a run for it
snap
knight f6
and
is gone
the venus flytrap closes in
bye bye rook
if you try to take any old way
i'm gonna take your knight at the end
so it seems like you could take here
twice
which would be great for white however
at the end of the day i'll take your
knight on e2
and i'm just winning i'm up in exchange
same thing if rook takes e7
rook takes e7 takes rook takes e2
and actually this is one of the
specialties
of richie and
very similar to other super gms
they're very precise with calculation
they're willing
to
give up upon because they calculate so
much ahead they know
that you can never take that pawn
and by the way just a side note and full
credit for knight c3
um
one thing about chess
that it's not a one solution game
a lot of times when you're doing puzzles
on
various sites they only accept one
solution
but what makes chess interesting
that it's a multiple solution or a no
solution game
and you never really know
if there is a solution or there is none
here we kind of realize there's two
solution in the position
and not just one
um
how do you decide which one you do and
which one you play well you choose the
one you're
100 sure is working
so i would presume that rockport saw
knight f6 probably considered knight
takes c32 but would have played knight
f6 because he can guarantee you
that he didn't mess up his calculation
so
that's kind of the reason
you always look for different moves
because one could be much simpler than
the other
but i digress
so for that reason nobody ever played
bishop h6 didn't want to take on up
seven because he saw that he'd lose the
exchange
takes takes
and
really chess sort of boils down
of activating
most of your pieces
so
if we look at this position
what will be the key weakness
in white's cap
there is a key weakness
in white's position
yeah the c3 pawn yep
the c3 pawn
is the key weakness in this position
so
based on that
it's much easier sort of
to guess
what moves you should be playing
you should be sort of regrouping
most of the lighter and heavier pieces
that you have left to attack it so
therefore he went to k8 with the simple
plan of taking an op like an important
open file and also sort of hoping to put
pressure on the c3 pawn
rook c1
bishop h4
bishop h4 is again sort of messing
with white's place saying okay i'm not
making your life easier if you would try
to walk on over
i will check you
i mean you of course you won't actually
but i will definitely push you back
and you won't really have any easy way
through we'll just go rook a2 there
so i am just sort of trying to restrict
your play as much as possible
and if you play g3 well already there
are some weaknesses in front of your
king that i want to use in that case
so g3
bishop f6
rook c2
b5 another move sort of fixing that
weakness
on
c3 and you can never ever move c4 again
one of the things that you can do in
chess though
is try to just trade it off as quickly
as possible
so b5 king g2 rook a3 and all those
things that i said earlier is coming to
fruition he fixes the weakness
make sure there's no c4 and he's ganging
up against the pawn
king f3
f6 bringing the king up king f5 king f7
and we're going to stop here for a
moment
we did accomplish a lot you're putting
pressure on the c pawn which is great
what do we think about that king on f5
is it a strength or is it a weakness
raise your hand if you think it's a
strength to have that king up on there
don't raise your hand if you don't want
to raise your hand
good good good
so that king on f5
is actually
he strength
any weakness
that king on f5
is good because it sort of pushes
the blacking back however
with that king up on the board
it is threatened to get mated
not right now because the king can flee
still
it can still flee
however it's still very close to these
light pieces of black
so it's not as far-fetched as it may
first see
bishop f4
goodish move
he's activating it
but again there's only one square left
for the king
g4
no squares left for the king row k1
knight c1 just one repetition
rook b3
rook a8 they're just tangoing around a
little bit
nothing really big happening
b1
okay one bishop h6
and this was the moment rapport decided
it is time it is time to do something if
i want to win this game
and if you want to win the game you have
to
look for more than just idly waiting
is white not fearing of getting mated
apparently not
now g3 check
you're chasing the king away
check
king here
knight e4
and the point
is actually twofold
not only does he get rid of a king that
was sort of pushing us down
he also manages to activate
his own pieces
activates this bishop
and he will be able to go kingy six
but
why is king e6 so important for us
in the first place
you could also think about a plan very
well said chat of going bishop g3 bishop
e1 going after the c3 pawn
great point that's one of the plans but
there is another plan
that is sort of important
our plan
is to go and break it open
because if we trade this off
there will be an h5 weakness
and if we win the h pawn we win the game
now usually one weakness is not enough
but talking about two weaknesses there's
one on c3 as well
so k2 happened take six
here
bishop f2 f5 bishop e1
bishop g5
and
wine actually resign
because he realized that yeah maybe i'm
not completely lost
which he actually is completely lost
a knight on a2 has no place to go to
it's absolutely closed in on that square
and its only purpose is to defend that
measly pawn on c3
but meanwhile
white is just going to shuffle around
black is just going to go pick some
cherries and some pawns
on the king's side just knight f6
whatever you do
we trade here let's say we trade and all
that block is going to do go knight f6
gonna takes h5
and you're just completely lost because
you have no way
of
continually defending the c pawn and
stopping my h pawn from promoting so
therefore
richie won
quite a nice game
where his opponent clearly was trying to
hold the fort but didn't manage to do so
so last but not least i want to end
on one last puzzle
and this one is from raw port rogic
and already
compared to the previous games he was 24
40ish
player
by this time he's playing is the same
year
he's 25 50.
so gained a whopping 110 points
since same year 110 points
and
this one is quite something
so it is richie to move
and show off some
quite nice tactical chops
the first move is obvious knight takes
d5
sacrificing more material and aiming at
that king and i take c1 of course the
critical question
now whenever you're trying to solve a
puzzle like these
you always have to wonder
am i going to be able to checkmate
with my light pieces the bishop and
knight is that enough
probably not
so you may want to involve
some more heavy artillery
97 check
king g7
and here richie plays
probably
one of the most astounding moves you can
do in this position
queen e6
why is screen e6 so fantastic well
normally
whenever you see a tactical solution it
is
bam bam boom you're winning
and he's like bam boom i sacrifice all
of my rooks
and i go queen e6 like i have time
there's there's no
reason
to fret there's nothing bad gonna happen
i'm just gonna stop you from playing
queenie one check
i'm gonna capture that thank you
and i'm saying you're just gonna lose
this game
black goes b4
and rockport says ah you want to involve
your queen
good story bro
d5
i ain't gonna let you in
knight d3
and
rapport finds
the fantastic solution
to my to move and when
so we are down a couple of material
so if we deli dally we may as well just
lose
so we gotta keep on rolling yes bishop
h6 check
if king h8 g7 is quite a cute little
smothering
king can go to g8 that's over protected
by everyone
so king takes h6
g takes h7
if king ticks
check
here checkmate
so here black decided to go king g5
queen g6 check obviously you got a roll
there's no literally no other checks
so if you're down material badly you got
to keep on rolling with those check if
king h4
we've got an elegant solution here
yep
rook takes i have to take
king h3
yep and queen g3 is checkmate
queen g6 nf king f4 then there's queen
g3 check
king e4 queen e3 mate
now the game ended after queen g6 check
but i mean let's give rapport his due
this is quite a picturesque way of
ending the game
so i really hope you guys enjoyed
this lecture
of how rapport sort of became this very
very aggressive and exciting player and
now a candidate
and i really hope you enjoyed
watching him demolish his opposition at
great style thank you so much for
watching
see you next time
[Music]
you